Let's start off by looking at some exponent patterns. Here are some expressions.
And here are those same expressions expanded based on the exponents. I have
three 3s multiplied together and three 2s multiplied together. Because the
exponents were 3 and 2. The same is true down here. I have two 2s and three 5s.
If I wanted to simplify these expressions, I would write the final answer with
one base and the exponent. For example, for this case I would have three 5s. So,
I could write this answer as 3 to the 5th. This second one's a little bit
tricky. I have a base of 2 and a base of 5. The bases are different, so I can't
combine these two bases and write them with an exponent. I have to keep them
separate. I still have 2 twos and 3 fives. When we simplify expressions with
exponents, we want to try and combine the exponents that have the same base. So
think about what I did here. What did I really do with these exponents to get
this answer? And what did we have to do in this case? And I know it seems weird
that we have an answer, that's the original question but sometimes that happens.
Sometimes we can't combine the powers. We could, of course, multiply each of
these out to get a number, but I wasn't focused on the number. I wanted to look
at the exponents and what we're doing with them.